foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth to work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships
the one and only Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money the call is free at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and some say it's worth exactly
what you pay for it all right let's go
to Michael and Topeka
kickoff this hour hey Michael how are
you
good good how are you doing better than
I deserve what's up
hey so I've uh I appreciate all the
Insight you've given me over the years
you've you've really helped me and my in
my personal life and just to make you
know more sound decisions so thank you
thank you for that well thank you
okay so I I had some friends who they
reached out to me last year and they
said hey we've got this business and you
know we've we're we're kind of
struggling we bought it and it didn't
really have the sales that we thought it
would and they were always trying to get
me to go in and sell for him and I will
say hey you know I've got a full-time
gig it's not something that I could
really fully commit to you know I you
know if you could you know send me your
last year's p l I'll try to see what I
can do but it uh you know it didn't it
didn't look too good I mean in their
first year they I think they netted only
you know ten thousand dollars and that
was after paying some employees so
it wasn't doing very good and I you know
these were good friends of mine and you
know they'd helped me out when I was in
kind of a blind one time so I said hey
you know let me let me see what I can do
towards the end of this year and I'll
make some cold calls around the area and
see what I can do to help generate some
sales well now they're starting to
they're starting to you know net roughly
you know anywhere from six to eight
thousand dollars in a month so they're
they're doing a lot better now and
they're still asking me like hey man
we'd like to see if you could you could
come in and do this full-time for us and
you know I just don't really even know
how to how to structure a deal you know
it's it's a couple guys and another
individual and one of the individuals
wants to get out and you know they've
got a hundred and ten thousand dollars
in debt so you know I'm saying hey I
don't wanna I don't want to invest in
this or absorb any debt but you know I
could do some sales can work as a
contractor you can't just work as a as
contracted labor for them
that's kind of what I propose but you
know that's something I've never done
you know I've again I have a full-time
gig and it was something where I didn't
really invest that much time I mean I
made like three or four phone calls and
was able to generate some some sales in
a very short period of time really just
did this you know kind of what do you
make Michael now
currently yeah
um roughly
you know 100 150 160 in your cell now
for a living
yes I do you don't like the company you
work for
I do I you know I they've treated me
very well and I like them and I I think
I think I was very kind of you to help
your friends
um there's a fur difference in um
throwing them a lifeline and getting in
the boat with them
I think I'm going to stay out of this
boat it sounds like it's sinking
yeah okay you've got one guy wanting to
get out they didn't know how to turn a
profit until they got you to make sales
and now they want you to come in there
and make sales and be an owner with them
um there's just there's more can go
wrong with this whole scenario this
isn't like two guys that were successful
and said come join us these are two guys
that couldn't do it and said come join
us
yeah yeah you know not a I mean if they
weren't your friends you would be
laughing
yeah yeah unfortunately and that's and
that's been kind of the challenges you
know I'm trying to explain to them you
know it's hey here's here's the sales
Pro they're not really sales guys you
know they're they on another side
business if you want to keep helping
them you know and keep your gig and keep
helping them to get you know until they
can get a good sales person hired maybe
you even help them train that guy and
they pay you one-offs for doing that
that's fine but don't don't go get in
this boat
how would you yeah I appreciate it if it
were me I would just set up some kind of
commission for every sale that I make
say that this is the percentage I want
and you're just structured you know on
1099 and and it's just easy just like
that and for that I'll make sales and
I'll also help you as your friend train
your first sales person if you'll get
them hired
yeah but I'm not but I'm not coming over
there
I appreciate I mean that was the
direction I was thinking of it as well
you know I've got some real I've got
I've got one really good friend who's a
banker
can you imagine if I wanted to no
I'm not going with him right he's a
banker I like him anyway but he's a
banker
you know no I'm not doing that just
because he's my friend no I mean there's
a difference here I mean what are you
supposed to do with your life and you
know it does not align you know the only
thing pulling you here is your need to
be good to your friends which makes you
a good guy but don't don't let that pull
you into this boat yeah definitely not
in any ownership capacity as it sounded
like they were trying to get you in
there I would just yeah yes I will take
a commission for every sale I make and I
put a I'd probably start with a really
short time limit on that too hey let's
try this for a couple of months and if
it goes well we can extend it just be
very clear with whatever terms you write
put it in writing we'll do a part-time
gig and I'll go over here as a side
hustle and help you guys get this thing
up and running do you get somebody hired
then I'll help you train them I'll bust
it for 90 days during that 90 days you
got to get somebody hired during the
next 90 days I'll train them and then
I'm out of here and you guys are going
to sail this boat by yourself love it
that's a plan good good point trade very
good point so good rule of thumb is this
and Michael's coming at this a little
bit differently but entree leadership we
run into this all the time
and I'm now the new host of the entree
leadership podcast if you haven't heard
so it's a small business podcast
answering questions so jump in on that
but one of the things we tell folks in
that world all the time is and I see it
with small business I mean and guys when
cat girls do it too uh gals do it too
but the way I always see it is a cup
about three guys are sitting around
having a beer
and then they decide they're going to
open us something together gosh
and this is the and every one of them
are dumber than a rock and the idea is
dumber than a rock but by God we're
going to do it together and their wives
are telling them please don't do this
please don't do this with guys if we're
going to go in the construction business
or we're going to do whatever ladies
open a dress shop and these are just
guaranteed ways to end up not friends at
the end of it to end up losing money at
the end of it and we tell people all the
time in those situations the only ship
that Won't Sail is a partnership
stay out of that one okay that one sinks
and so if you if if you really do want
to go in business with your friend one
of you own it and the other one worked
for them
if you're really going to do it so
Michael the only way I would even
consider moving over there is if you
bought this business that's that's
losing and horrible for a dollar and the
guys that can't run it get to be your
new employees
but I wouldn't do that either by the way
in this case but um but that's the only
way I'm going to do it I'm going to be
in control of the situation because
there's all these things that we call
the D's that can happen
um divorce yes drug use
default disability death when any of
these happen to your partner you get to
work with your partner spouse after that
um
so he gets to to a boy start something
that's successful they get a divorce all
of a sudden what you're working with
your buddy's ex-wife because she got the
business in the divorce yeah this is
food yeah see what I mean yeah that's
scary stuff in the plan the contracts
are never it's never in writing very
well there's always this gray area death
will undo it even if it's in writing
this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
cschm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America with debt payments and now with
inflation stealing more and more of your
paycheck we know a lot of folks are
scared out there
and you should hear the rumors of banks
collapsing and you hear all these things
and you're you can't you know hardly
afford your groceries we understand
you know what you shouldn't have to live
that way
when Sharon and I went broke we finally
looked in the mirror and said that's it
I've had it
I'm not going to be like this anymore
and um well if you're ready to do some
new things if you want different results
you have to do different things by the
way if you keep doing the same thing
over and over again expect a different
result that's called the definition of
insanity right
so you need to try something new if you
want a different result if you don't
like the way the the Jade made famous
brownies this week on uh Instagram I saw
her Instagram if you don't like the way
the brownies turned out you change the
recipe right and so hey you want to
change the recipe it's time to get into
Financial Peace University our nine
lesson course that'll teach you how to
beat debt and build wealth nearly 10
million people have taken Financial
Peace University and uh that means that
we're the largest and best known
personal finance successful personal
finance class in America hello so check
it out Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU ramseysolutions.com FPU now you've
started a class right that's right
you're coordinating a class on a virtual
class with like a thousand people in it
that's right we're four four lessons in
you're doing like a fast uh faster than
you're doing more than one a week that's
right most of the time when you hear
about it it's a nine week course we Fast
Track it a lot of that was just to test
out what that can be like in five weeks
and make sure you're doing nine weeks
and five nine weeks and five or two
lessons a week yep okay and these people
are cutting up credit cards Dave that's
what they're supposed to change in their
lives yep the point is they're not
scared to make those changes yeah and I
love that yeah I mean like a thousand
people cutting up credit cards on Zoom
Yep this is fun Yep they're raising
their hand to say I want to come on
camera and cut up my credit cards I love
it I love it on air plasectomies on air
we used to do those we used to do
plasectomies a long time ago and it
would like be like the most creative way
and people would go on the air with
their AR-15 and shoot them uh they would
go on the air with their uh with their
chipper yeah the log chipper yes yes you
know on the air with any you know
blenders we destroyed a lot of blenders
in America back then well yeah because
now you can never use it again after you
run a credit card in it so uh because it
you know it's toxic right I think the
credit card the credit card companies
are on to us Dave because they're
they're making a metal now yeah and
they're hard to they're hard to cut
three Snips tin snips that'll do it get
out the old uh grinder oh yeah put them
in put it in the meat grinder if you're
gonna be if you're gonna make metal ones
we're gonna have to involve either
Firearms or power tools love it yeah I'm
here for it Dave I'm in for this this
works or boats firearms and power tools
yes now I'm having fun all right Paul's
with us in Indianapolis hey Paul welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey what's going on hey man how can we
help
uh so I am in uh
let's see here baby step four five six
uh I've got a friend who a great man
really close friend hard-working guy uh
he's going to buy a flip house he's
gonna flip it and he was he's not an
investor but he was wanting me to maybe
chip in and and so here's where I'm at
is I'm struggling to you know really get
in gear and pay off my house
um
and so I've got this extra money sitting
there and I'd like to invest it uh I'm
not going to invest it with him this
time around because it just seems like
the numbers don't make sense uh but I've
got I guess two questions one would be
is me investing in his little project is
that me putting him in debt and would
that change our like really close
friendship and should I just avoid that
all together or is that an investment
and then my my backup question would be
convince me to pay off my house to
instead of putting 20 grand towards his
little flip uh putting it on my house
well we'll start with that one if your
house was paid for and your friend came
and said hey go get a mortgage
and we'll use that to do a flip with
what would you say
uh I tell him yeah he can jump off that
house go fly a kite this is the same
thing this is the same thing we just
reversed it right so exact same
principle
um it's just it's just you know the
money's laying there and you hadn't put
it on the house yet
um so it needs to go in the house now on
the other thing
um how are you all structuring the deal
are you going to be partners like you're
an owner with him no no it's it's kind
of like hey just give me this money and
in six months or maybe a year I'll give
you 10 back and I'm looking at like 20
grand 10 like you're gonna I'm gonna
make two thousand dollars on this and
just seems so open-ended that I'm not
interested but I think I know he'll get
good at this and he'll do it more and
more and then he'll come back to me in
the future and it's like wait a minute
is there an underlying principle that I
should say no from principle
um
well you are loaning in money you're the
more you're the banker you're the banker
yeah if you want to be in the banking
business with your friend that's you can
do that I don't I don't there you go I
mean that's what it is it's a loan he's
not asking you to give him the money
it's not a gift
he's going to repay the loan plus 10 at
his convenience when it sells
haha and I don't want to be the bank
that's the long way can I tell you can I
tell you a quick story Paul I have I
have a family member who has that
relationship with a lot of their her
friends and the relationship is I'm
giving you this money you're going to go
invest in property or I'm giving you
this money and you're gonna go do this
and sometimes it takes longer for these
things to pay out if they pay out and
there has been times where we've gone
out to dinner and maybe we're at that
person's restaurant that she invested in
and instead of saying hey do you want to
go eat at my friend's restaurant the
languages hey let's go eat here he owes
me anyway
this is my good friend and do you see
what I'm saying now it's a transaction
between them she's thinking oh he owes
me money I'm just gonna go eat here for
free after all I invested here so it
changes the way yeah
yeah you can you can he can say give me
the money all he wants but he means loan
me the money
yeah yeah because that's that's the
actual business Arrangement that you're
coming to and if you put that in writing
and you loaned him money and he gave you
10 back
um yeah you're the principle is yes the
borrower slave to the lender you just
changed the relationship that's the
principle you're violating the second
principle you're violating is dumber
than crap to make only 10 on 20 grand
tied up for an indefinite period of time
in a high risk scenario with a guy who
does not have a proven track record I
would dump it in mutual funds 6 000
times before I would put it in that
um if you want to do flips go do flips
if he's going to give you 50 of the
profits and they're six thousand dollars
of profit and you put in 20 grand now we
got something to the numbers actually
give me a reason to think but 10 percent
no thank you
no thank you no deal
hey guys if you want to help us out we
would appreciate some help and a matter
of fact a bunch of you have been doing
it because our numbers are way up on the
podcast way up on our ratings thank you
so share this show if you watch it on
YouTube or you listen to it as a podcast
or you let's do it on talk radio or TBN
tell people about it whether it's
through a link just click the little
linky thing and do it if it's a podcast
right subscribe to the show if you're
doing this as a podcast or YouTube
Follow subscribe whatever it is in that
particular genre jump in there and and
make it to where it regularly shows up
both of these things really help the
algorithm and the other thing that helps
put it forward and lets people see it
that never even heard of us before is if
you rate it with five stars now we don't
really need any one star ratings your
mother said if you ain't anything nice
to say don't say nothing at all so just
stay away if you want to troll troll
something else but uh yeah seriously we
need High Five Star Ray ratings and we
need follows and we need shares and if
you do that it doesn't cost you anything
if you like what you hear tell people
about it Sharon and I went to the
preview of this movie that uh just came
out about last week we went to preview
about four weeks ago the Jesus
Revolution so good it is absolutely
fabulous and see that's what you do what
you and I just did you when you see
something great you share about it I
just shared it Jesus Revolution go watch
this go watch it's so good hand is very
well done very well acted incredible
story arc very well written and the
actual story and the story behind the
story are all fabulous very good Jesus
Revolution go watch it it's incredible
see that's what you do you like
something you share it you give them a
five star review we just gave him five
stars just then this
there's the Ramsey Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trustee
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Richard
and Angela are with us hey guys how are
you hi all right thank you welcome where
do you guys live uh Stockton California
all right good to have you guys welcome
and how much debt have you paid off
we paid off three hundred ten thousand
five hundred and twenty five dollars I
love it yes how long did this take it
took 33 months wow wow and your range of
income during that time
started off at a 173 000 and went up to
131 000. 231 oh 131 up I went from 173
down to 131. no let me repeat that and I
got it backwards 73 000. oh from 73 okay
to 130 oh I misunderstood my fault okay
cool what do you all do for a living
I am a resource specialist at a
community college and I'm a material
store supervisor to State of California
I recently retired oh congratulations
thank you all right so you put ten
thousand dollars a month towards this
average now you must have had some money
you put through you through with this
what kind of debt was this you paid off
oh it was everything it was
um dental bills credit card bills Home
Remodeling bills and it was two houses
whoa your home included yes all right
wow you're 100 debt free yes we are we
are looking at weird people especially
in California yes Wow way to go guys
congratulations thank you okay so three
almost three years ago yes some kind of
a switch flipped what happened they got
you guys on this Ramsay stuff well
started well before that it actually
started in
2006-2007 we took Financial Peace
University with our church and
after we completed the class we were
kind of doing ramsey-ish
we had a rental home that we owed less
money on than we owed on our credit
cards so we kind of decided to flip the
switch a little bit and we were going to
pay that house off first and then pay
everything else off well lo and behold
2008-9 came and I got laid off so
um that kind of changed things quite a
bit I took another job working part-time
full-time and
10 years later several jobs later you
know here we are
when did you lean in and stop being ish
33 months ago we leaned in and stopped
being ish when we got the house paid off
but we went back to using credit cards
and such when I got laid off so we got
all that taken care of and then you know
we thought we were doing okay and we
took your class again at another church
and we decided this is what we want to
do we want to now it's time oh so you
really you really got like a D in the
first class so you had to go back and
repeat the class and get your a yeah
right sometimes it's like that Dave
sometimes it takes a couple of times to
make it stick am I right right yes yes
well I'm glad it did stick hey what are
these houses worth I'm just curious
uh well one is worth uh about 580 000
and the other one is worth 350 000. so
are you guys like baby step millionaires
yeah
[Applause]
yes yes this plan is so good even if you
have to it it works I mean here we are
yeah very cool I would like to say uh I
I retired because I got injured on the
job and then I started getting sick and
I started having what you call tias I
was the last one putting me in the
hospital and and so that that kind of
solidified it with us to just retire
because I had to get some shoulder
surgery and some back surgery and just
the nerves in my back and neck is all
all messed up so it's just best for me
to retire so I was able to retire and
we were able to get out of debt sounds
like a lot of years are really hard work
yes yes it was so 33 months ago we had a
plan
we decided that we were going to sell
our primary house in Stockton and we
were going to move into that paid off
rental property in Sacramento and that
place had been a rental for well over 25
years so we were going to remodel it and
we were just going to turn it into our
dream home we were really going to make
it ours
so we put our house up for sale and we
got connected with the bad realtor and
some shoddy contractors so
we had to sue one of the contractors oh
yes we had to sue them but before we put
it up for sale our real estate agent she
came in and she wanted us to make a few
changes she said oh I think you need to
remodel the kitchen the house will sell
much faster if you remodel the kitchen
and you need new carpet upstairs you
need bathroom floors change your blinds
and we did all of that and guess how we
paid for it cat I hope cash please tell
me with that credit card no with one of
the 11 credit cards that we paid off so
our plan was to put all of this on
credit and then pay it off you know when
we sold the house then the kitchen's
Anna she likes the house again and she
decides to stay well
we had a person wanted to buy they were
first time home buyer it went into
escrow and the deal fell through
so in the meantime you know we're
starting to pack and we're excited about
moving and getting the contractor
started and they really wanted to start
soon because it was you know the
beginning stages of covid they had that
Transportation issue going on where you
know stuff was just sitting on docks and
such and so our contractor said well you
know we don't know if we're going to be
able to get this in three months so you
know we need to sign this deal now so we
did
uh bottom line we ended up telling them
we no longer needed their services
they threatened to sue us we had to get
a lawyer to basically threaten to sue
them and so on and so by the grace of
God we were able to get out of this
contract and my husband said we need to
sell it
and I will say that um
um
when I first heard your program I had
just bought a brand new truck
and it seemed like everything you said
was sell the truck sell the truck sell
the truck
I love the truck
so I did now that you are completely
free how's it feel well it feels great
it really does but it just really took a
long time to get there you know we we
went through so much particularly with
this contractor because you know
probably now about I don't know 20
something months into this you know
we're standing in front of a house that
looks like it's been totally abandoned
boarded up Windows boarded up doors and
you know the contractor kept telling us
oh the windows are coming in the doors
are coming in but bottom line we're
standing there in front of a house that
used to make two thousand dollars a
month in income that we would use to pay
on our other house Angela I'm on a short
circuit you because you're gonna miss
your debt-free screen
you're free now that's what matters all
the good news is you made the corner I
apologize for interrupting you I'd love
to hear the whole story Richard and
Angela Stockton California baby steps
middle millionaires 311 paid off in 33
months making 73 to 131 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
three two one we're dead free
quite a journey to get there
I know that's right this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
if you're a new listener and you're
still trying to figure out what all of
these code words we use around Ramsey
are like baby steps or debt snowballs or
all that hey jump on the website at
ramseysolutions.com click the get
started button uh it's all completely
free and it will show you exactly where
you are financially in the baby steps
start to teach you the vernacular the
things we're talking about around here
and how we're showing people this
because a little bit of sometimes people
that have been listening to this show
for 15 years call in and we talk to them
and if you really hadn't been around you
don't even know what we all just said
and so we want to we want to get you in
the loop on that we got a bunch of new
listeners and new viewers out there and
I want to be able to help you
ramseysolutions.com
it's a free service click the get
started button Sarah is in San Francisco
hey Sarah welcome to the Ramsay show
hello it's an honor to speak to you both
today YouTube what's up
um I have a question so I have a couple
brokerage accounts with more than 500
000 in them and I was wondering if I
needed to worry about sipc limits of
protection
um and break up those accounts between
different brokerage firms
um
the sipc I mean you've got the money
invested in stocks or bonds or mutual
funds right
yes okay so if that brokerage uh company
went broke it doesn't you don't lose
your money this is not like a bank
account
okay because you own you own what have
you got it in stocks or what what's it
in
um a few bonds okay you have an actual
account that owns I mean you own a bond
you own uh a mutual fund you own mutual
fund shares so if the company that is
giving you access to those shares goes
broke you don't lose the shares you just
you just have to find a different way to
access them
so the sipc has more to do with if
they're fraudulent they steal your money
or something like that but if you
actually have statements showing you
know account numbers and ownership
positions in these things you actually
own something
the way you would lose your money is if
the companies that you owned went broke
like the stock that you owned went broke
does that make sense
like if you had Apple stock and apple
went out of business I'll make I'll make
it up I'll just print it let's say you
let's say your brokerage accounts are
with Merrill Lynch if Merrill Lynch goes
broke you don't lose your money
because you're not invested in Merrill
Lynch they're just the access portal
through which you are handling your
Investments it's different than if you
put your money in a bank the bank takes
possession of that money they you I mean
you have an account there but they're
not a broker they are owning that money
and they can screw that up as happened
in your neighborhood last week Sarah
yeah
it's a good question it's a different
uh situation so no I mean if you want to
do that that's fine I have all of my
Investments with one brokerage account
one broker one brokerage firm one
advisor one of our smart investor Pros
okay uh I don't need seven and it's
millions and I don't need seven
different people and to get sipc
protection because I actually own mutual
funds in XYZ mutual fund and I I
actually own something there and so
that's the difference in see that's a
good way of reminding everybody this you
don't make money when I used to work for
a guy a thousand years ago he said don't
be a loner be an owner so when you put
money in a bank you're loaning them your
money and they're paying you interest
not much but they're paying you interest
uh when you put money into an investment
you're an owner yeah so if you want to
make money you need to be an owner not a
loaner there's never any money with
putting your money in a bank and so
apparently even owning the bank is bad
but well you know I I get where her
question is coming from I was watching
The Today Show this morning and they
were going over what you should do with
your money and they're saying you know
if you have over 500 000 in the bank you
know you're only covered up to 250 so to
break it up and all these things and I'm
thinking to myself who's why do you have
just five hundred thousand dollars just
sitting in the bank like go invest that
money exactly
just go invest it and uh we talked about
this on the air yesterday but we'll just
segue into it for a second you need to
understand a lot of people are panicking
right now and if you didn't hear us talk
about this yesterday over that uh One
Bank collapsing actually and then the
FDIC stepped in and uh scored some other
banks in a similar situation two more
probably gonna see a couple more go down
if yeah she's probably gonna take them
over but these are not Banks that are
your neighborhood bank right okay
88 of the depositors
had more than 250 000 in there
this was a bank full of money from Tech
startups Venture capitalists hedge fund
the Uber Rich it's in Silicon Valley
okay so this was not your grandmother's
CD right at the bank this is not what
was going on over there there's a
completely different scenario and so the
typical bank would be the other way
around they would have like 88 percent
would be covered right the 88 of their
deposits are 60 or 65 percent of their
deposits are under 250 000 and so
they've got full FDIC coverage for all
of their depositors uh that are you know
that fall into that now again I in my
local bank I have over 250 with our
businesses and a lot well over that but
I'm not worried about my local bank I
did not pull money out because the
banking system
it's not okay it's just not so you're
you're going to be okay calm down and
don't rush out and buy gold
and this should just calm your butt down
so that's not her not I mean she's
asking a reasonable question because
she's got this right in her face it's in
her neighborhood but and it's a
different kind of a question it's a
great question by the way sir but the uh
yeah but but overall overall folks with
the the whole and the other thing that
happened from this was the bond market
they were they were liquidating a bunch
of bonds and the bond market uh the uh
surged causing rates to go down
simultaneously mortgage rates went down
so if you're going to buy a house and
you want to lock in a mortgage call
Churchill Mortgage today and get your
mortgage locked in before it goes back
up by the end of the freaking week and
this stuff calms down good point so you
might save as much as a half of a
percent this week let's go if you move
on this fast uh and so if you're
thinking about buying a house in the
next few months that you can get like 90
day locks and stuff with your mortgage
company like Churchill Mortgage that we
recommend go do that it changes
everything
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Sergio's in
Dallas Sergio what's up
hey thank you so much for taking my call
Dave sure how can we help
uh well long story short
um my wife's grandparents which are
still alive they uh kind of gifted her
their home but they're kind of they're
selling it too but it's going to be
taken out of her inheritance
and we we took it it's in a different
town and everything but we took it we're
actually in the process of moving in
right now and uh my question is what to
do with our existing house right now you
have a mortgage on it
sell it
okay
you don't have enough money to be in the
rental business you don't have the money
to pay for that house
the other house paid for that granny
gave you
yes so now you're dead free
yeah there you go if you were 100 debt
free would you would you think if you
called me up and said hey Jade I want to
buy a rental property and go in debt
what would Jay tell you
bingo
you would search the country to find
your house as the perfect rental house
so that's the best way to look at it
get rid of it live in the house that
you're in debt free that's exciting
stuff where are the grandparents now
it's a big blessing they're in a nursing
home oh okay
very sad we're actually in the process
of we're having an estate soaked right
now selling other stuff and the house
has been deeded to you and your wife
no honey there is no there's only one
it's a yes or no get the deed
if the deed is not yours the house is
not yours you haven't got the real
estate doesn't transact on a handshake
son go get the deed signed now
or don't move in this house
this is family crap that's getting ready
to go sideways buddy you're gonna have a
problem here get the deed in your name
there's no sort of kind of in real
estate that's not how it works you're
gonna find out the hard way
[Music]
on your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show
this is the place where we help people
get out of debt feel well through work
that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
thanks for hanging out with us Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today starting off this hour is Patrick
in Fresno California hi Patrick welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call
here's my question
so I've got over a quarter of a billion
in my retirement account and over the
years I've seen it go up and down
and after hearing the news about uh what
what went down this weekend you know the
two banks in the Silicon Valley
um I'm wondering if I should take money
out of my retirement and pay off my
credit card debt that's my my major debt
is my credit card followed by my home my
my car is paid for so it's basically
those two bits that I'm working with
what do you have your money what do you
have your money invested in
and um you know when I left the county I
had it in their retirement plan a 401
and 457. in mutual funds
correct what's that got to do with the
bank
uh well last time that all happened in
2008 uh I just shut the door on that
book because it looks so bad you know is
it going to fall and I'm going to see
this money diminish would it be better
off to use the assets I have now pay off
my debt and that way the money I earn is
mine I can put it in the bank and invest
it how old are you
I am going to be 60 this year I want you
to pay off your credit card debt but not
for that reason
how much credit card debt do you have
about 27
000. yeah 23 to pay off my home
23 000 pays off your home
correct and we're on a good uh Pace to
do that you know I'll have that how much
money do you have not counting your
retirement
uh and not a whole lot you know we have
about five grand in the bank what's your
household income
about it fluctuates between UH 60 and
70.
[Music]
all right and your money is currently
all in your 401k and you still work for
the county
uh no I don't oh you've already moved on
yeah about the 2 the two half years ago
and when you know when it started to hit
the fan I go you know what
uh I just got hit up for a position and
so I'm working part-time right now okay
all right and what do you what is your
household income today
um
I'm with Jade I would pay off your house
and I would pay off your credit cards if
you cut up your credit cards and if you
get on a budget because you've been
really really you've been really sloppy
with money
the two good things you've done you've
done a good job paying down your
mortgage and you've done a good job uh
building up some retirement uh but your
monthly management of money is not good
it's chaotic and out of control and
you're going to end up backing credit
card debt it just because you pay them
off doesn't fix it if you don't stay
under control is that right
all right that's the goal is to get it
all under control and and stop that you
know stop bleeding out so yeah but the
credit card debt is the symptom it's not
the problem
okay and so we you know yes we can pay
off the credit cards but they will grow
back if you don't get yourself on a
system on a budget monthly are you
married
yes and working with your wife the two
of you sitting down and we have a
spending plan where every dollar has a
name and we don't spend more than we
make because we're not in Congress
what's your yes my wife thank God has
that under control she does a great job
for me what's your Full Nest Egg
combined
because you mentioned the 250 000 in
your retirement accounts what what other
money do you have in retirement does
your wife have money in retirement too
yeah not really no uh during my career
she raised the kids and stood home and
you know that that was our a way of uh I
just want to make sure that you I just
want to make sure that you working
full-time or working part-time is the
right choice right now with what you
have in retirement
all right that's something I'm I'm
looking at changing you know picking up
more work maybe not with this position
that I'm that I'm currently in but
picking up a work elsewhere because if
all you have is the 250 that's not
really uh am I going to or not it's a I
I must
it's not enough to retire on
oh right right I I got that yeah so
they're ready to retire just yet so
Patrick here's what we would tell you we
tell you to do several things and if you
don't do all of them then any one of
them might be wrong okay so number one
okay and re-engage a full-time career
number two build a budget with your
spouse that the two of you are both
participating in and get your emergency
fund built up from five thousand to
three to six months of expenses then
number three yes pulling fifty thousand
out and be a hundred percent debt free
which will help that budget and build
that savings up because now you don't
have any payments but I don't want it to
grow back and number four get out the
credit cards tonight and cut them all up
have a plastic to me okay I'm not
kidding it's not a joke no no and no I
I've threatened to do that before okay
now I'm not threatening yeah this is you
need to change your lifetime because if
you don't you're going to end up at 65
with 200 000 and you will have forty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
because it'll grow up right no no no
it'll grow back the path I want to go
down I know I don't want you to go down
that so and then the last thing is this
um do not jump in and out of Investments
based on what you hear on the news ever
okay uh the the stock market is not
going to crash the banking system is not
going to crash this is a completely
different kind of Bank a completely
different kind of scenario than 2008 and
so I am not pulling one dime out of my
mutual funds today
or nor did I last week nor will I next
week and I'm 62. I'm older than you
and I don't have much time left yeah but
um but with the time I have I'm going to
continue to invest okay so you get you
know here it's serious stay in your
Investments quit making your moves based
on the news you can't let the the color
of the ticker tape on the news and the
music that they use denote your
investing strategy when the ticker is is
read and it says breaking news and the
music is you know and it just gets your
heart rate up and you start sweating and
you're like oh my God oh my God you
can't let that you know they don't ever
do that when it's green I know right
they don't have like happy music no they
don't breaking news it's awesome yeah
nobody does that that never happens it's
always breaking news the Market's down
and you're gonna die of a tornado if it
bleeds it leads and it leads people to
do dumb stuff and it leads them to do
things that are not good for them in the
long haul and so we've just gotta these
are the times where you lock in and if
you just hold oh by the way I gotta hit
one more thing hit it
like 2008. okay let me tell you what let
me tell you what I did stock market went
from 13 000 to 6500 you know how much I
took out none you know what after that
it went to 35 38
000 from 6 500. you know what a million
dollars does when it goes up from six
thousand to thirty thousand it becomes
five million dollars nobody talked about
that
because I didn't get out
I rode the roller coaster so I kind of
hope it does what 2008 did okay because
I'll be getting in I know that's on sale
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50 percent off everything
site-wide visit blinds.com today to
learn more
thank you
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America
our question today is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
the Ramsay show is sponsored by
neighborly uh they anything from repairs
to maintenance to remodeling stuff like
Mr Rooter Mr Electric uh Molly may you
know these names they're all part of the
neighborly family so go to
neighborly.com and get local experts and
home service providers to take care of
you and they'll schedule a service today
today's question of the day comes from
Jeremy in the baby steps millionaires
group you can find that on Facebook I'm
47 years old if I plan to retire early
like say 50 to 55 should I be maxing out
my 401k or funding more Investments that
I can pull from before I turn 60. my
Roth is fully funded each year in
January it's a really good question
um you know I have more questions for
you Jeremy I would want to know if you
have any debt I'd want to know if your
house is paid off those are the things
that I would prioritize first is making
sure that you're out of debt making sure
that you are going from baby step four
and five and six and then if you're in
baby step seven you could do um
additional funding into different
Investments
um it says that he's funding fully
funding his Roth in January every year
it sounds like he's got extra money if I
were you I would work to pay that house
off and then from then on if you wanted
to throw money into I guess a taxable
brokerage or something that you could
get into before you hit 59 and a half
I'm not mad at that what do you think
Dave yeah the the term that people use
is Bridge investing to make a bridge
from 55 to 59 and a half and so we'll
have this other lump in good good mutual
fund Investments to get there but you're
right that's a baby step seven activity
so if he is at baby step seven and he's
dead free house and everything has his
emergency fund maxing out his retirement
can I also what else can I do or can I
even slow down retirement a little bit
and throw some at the bridge because I'm
gonna need something to eat on and build
up a pile of like you said just taxable
mutual funds what you're looking for
there are what are called Low turnover
mutual funds and their mutual funds that
don't sell the stocks inside of them
very often and so it does not act
activate the gains for taxes so you
don't pay taxes on gains as they occur
unless you sell it and uh that way it's
basically a tax deferred investment like
a good place to do that kind of a thing
it's a no-brainer is an S P 500 because
it's going to have I was looking at one
that I had a two and a half percent
turnover ratio which means that uh 97
and a half percent of the stocks do not
sell in a year so 97.5 percent of the
gains approximately are not going to be
taxed in a year so you would that's a
low turnover creates the it's not taxed
until you finally do sell it would the
fees on something like that be lower as
well since it's not since the funds
aren't being swapped out as much yeah
there will be I mean you can buy it as a
no load you could also get it through
your smart investor Pro if you've got a
smart Booster Pro managing your
portfolio they can just throw that in
with what they're doing it's not a
problem at all I use a lot of time of
low turnover mutual fund investing to
park money in until I get ready to buy
my next piece of real estate what I do
with it so I love it but uh uh and it's
you know uh I can I can handle the uh
volatility mathematically and
emotionally of the stock market going up
or down and so that but that's at a
different place so that's a baby step
four thing you're looking for a bridge
bridge investing do not start that as
Jade said until you're dead free though
that's right is with us in Boston hey
Angela how are you
I'm great Dave hi Jade I'm thrilled to
talk to you guys thank you for the work
you do thank you how can we help
all right so I'm cleaning up stupid
um I came to the baby steps maybe two
years ago but before that um I bought my
first home and it was you know by the
baby stuff standards well out of my pay
or you know my pay so I'm cleaning up
what I did I did a
um I had a loan modification
um that was performed I had an FHA loan
and what was done was a partial Claim by
Hud so it's a interest-free
um loan of a hundred thousand dollars
that was removed from my mortgage
balance to reduce my payments um when I
fell behind
um just to keep me in the home so where
I am now is I've I've paid off about
forty thousand dollars on baby step two
I'll be finished with baby step two in
about three months and I'm just looking
ahead to see
um if I should be paying off this
partial claim even though it's tied to
my mortgage and baby step six
or should I be pulling that in since I
have that ability to to pay it down um
through HUD what's your household what's
your household income
I make between 138 and 140. I would I
would leave it as a baby step six
okay because I would treat it like it's
a second mortgage or a home equity loan
and we do not pay those off if they're
more than half your annual income
okay until you get to babysitter six now
when you get to baby step six you're
going to work your way through it but
you said it's an interest-free loan they
took a they carved a piece of the
mortgage off set it to the side and put
a moratorium on it with no interest
right yes I'm in no hurry on that one
okay I do want to get rid of it but I'm
in no hurry would I okay would I
prioritize the interest bearing portion
of the loan before the interest free how
would I yes I recommend I don't know
what they're I don't know what their
rules are on that kind of a modification
but if they allow it yeah you'd pay off
your either be the last one you paid off
of the two
okay but uh but I'm not going to keep it
like a pet either I mean but we're gonna
set it over at baby step six and we're
not gonna be here eight years from now
and still be going 10 years from now
still be going no I'm not going to pay
it off it's no interest no I do want to
get rid of it but
um and they may not allow you to do that
additional principal reduction on your
first mortgage until you get that
modification paid
yes it would be logical it would be
logical that they don't allow it
but who knows with HUD I mean you know
logic is a federal government logic has
nothing to do with this
exactly yeah the the partial portion
isn't due until the first mortgage is
either paid off or the home is sold
and if you pay off the first mortgage is
it due in full instantly or you have to
begin paying on it yes it's doing full
instantly so you can't pay the furniture
yeah you can't pay the first mortgage
off then because you're gonna have a
balloon of 100 Grand looking at you
it would I they they allow partial so
you can almost just throw money at it to
reduce it but it can't yeah you can get
it down get it down to 20 000 bucks or
something and then reach over and knock
off the hundred right okay but that's
all at baby step six
okay thank you so much when did you do
this
oh Dave uh when did you do the
modification
this was in 2018
2019 I'm sorry and the basis that they
gave you this this relief was based on
what
um hardship was between jobs and the the
criteria was
um my current mortgage balance and
payments
um did not match my my income in between
you know those jobs so there was a trial
period you know after I got my new job
that I could pay the new
um you know reduced and modified
modified loans so it was a hardship
application and how long did it take you
to get the hardship application through
I haven't seen one of these in decades
I'm really interested in this because I
it hasn't happened much you pulled off
something pretty unusual it was a
blessing you know I
how much hassle was it to push this
through
I would say I was about three payments
behind going into four so it was a loss
mitigation through my my mortgage
company
um there was maybe a month of
application with documentation hardship
documentation yeah proof of income
um and then there was a three-month
trial period where they modified and
basically paused my old mortgage and I
had to do a trial payment based on the
new modification monthly payment you had
to prove you could make the new payment
yes and then after that that was proven
we went into basically a new closing
with an FHA and I closed on my modified
um took it off the books of your own
mortgage company too it's not setting
that your own mortgage company is it
yes so if you look at my my
um yeah my oh what I owe it's removed
from even my credit
um yeah it's sitting over at HUD HUD
they bought the loan back and redid it
that's amazing I haven't seen that in a
long time you did a that's a that's a
fetal strength good job good job keep
your house and get the mess cleaned up
now wow wow this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today on the debt free stage in
the Ramsey Solutions Lobby Luis and
Delia are with us hey guys how are you
hi welcome where do you live
we live in Houston Texas Spring Houston
Texas yeah Houston welcome to Nashville
and how much data have you guys paid off
oh gosh uh we paid 132
685. all right way to go how long did
this take uh around five years good for
you and your range of income during that
time well we started with 64 000 and our
current income is uh 135. all right good
what do y'all do for a living I'm a
mechanical engineer and I'm a high
school teacher okay so what kind of debt
was the 133
uh it was credit cards we had 10 credit
cards all maxed out and we had card
loans and student loans wow normal so
tell us about this five-year Journey
that's a long journey yeah we when we
got married we just started just
thinking that that was normal that you
know you pay you you always have a car
loan you always you know just use your
credit cards and shuffling credit cards
and it got to the point where we were
just you know got to the cashier and had
to flip credit cards so our marriage was
in a desperate mode really so we uh
learned from our church Grace woodlands
and they promoted the the class
so I was like let's take it let's we
have to invest the money obviously
uh and uh
well you signed us up I was not on board
at the beginning because it was about
numbers and I just I'm not a fan
you know I don't like math
um and um we he took me to the class and
I was hooked on the very first class I
was just like okay we're doing this but
um and then we started seeing that our
marriage was improving because we were
communicating a lot we ever sat down to
do our budget meeting
and uh we we got excited after our first
credit card was paid off and then we
could just keep going and going and
going and uh I picked up like extra
tutorials at work and like extra duties
they always paid something extra for
that and we just went gazelle intensity
wow I love that so you get to the the
register and you're trying One credit
card that one's not working you're going
to the next one that one's not working
and that was that that breakthrough
moment that you guys said we're we're
changing our life yeah so what was the
hardest part
I think the farthest part was talking so
you know it to myself
I'm the free spirit and he's a nerd okay
um and um the voice of Dave Ramsey on my
brain he was like do you want it or do
you need it and until this point like we
transitioned that to our our daughters
and uh that was the hardest part saying
no to myself and wait until we got the
cash for it
what was it about the first class that
hooked you that you thought okay maybe I
can do this first of all you're very
funny
that's helpful yeah it helps the
medicine go down yeah and uh it's just
seeing that the people actually do this
at first it was like this is just a scam
it's not going to work
um and then we took the class so many
times at church we took it like five
times but we took it that many times
because we needed the accountability
from the people going through the same
journey and we took it so many times at
a church was like you should be the
coordinators for a church I love it and
now we're coordinating all right thank
you very good so the former reluctant
spouse is now a coordinator oh yeah
there we go I like it the medicine went
down yeah good for you all okay now that
you've coordinated all these classes
you've been through classes you paid off
a hundred and thirty three thousand
dollars what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is
consistency yes consistency and we
started seeing the Improvement big steps
and we both were on the same Approach at
first he was the one like no we're doing
this we're not buying that so I I hated
all that process but then until I saw
how much minimal payment we were seeing
it on our credit cards and then he told
me we how could I spend all this money
on traveling or on whatever we wanted to
but we couldn't because we had to pay
our debt so that that's when we both
decided okay we're doing this as a team
and and we just went off honestly also I
want to say the every dollar Bud uh app
oh yes it helps because she can actually
just it's just easier for her just she
just thought I can just drag and drop
where it goes in the budget yeah I love
it and you don't have you keep the
budget easy and you don't have to be
good at math I had an Excel spreadsheet
and she hated that I can't imagine I can
imagine yeah I love that I can't imagine
an engineer with an Excel spray that's
never happened before yeah that is so
good so way to go you guys very very
well done we're proud of you thank you
thank you who was cheering you on
um people were in a church yes and our
family
um my in-laws they also do the Ramsey
they completely paid off the house and
um we um every time they were into
advice it was like okay you can do this
we did it you can guys do it too so
family members in our church yeah yeah
and that's a a class that you said Grace
Woodlands yeah that's a great place
great way to go guys excellent thanks
Grace Woodland for teaching the class
yeah a couple right here
yeah yeah your churches out there this
is what happens when you do this way to
go guys very very well done good stuff
we got the live and give box for you
it's got the baby steps millionaires
book which you will be on your way to
being one of those now soon and of
course The Total Money Makeover book
give that away and get it moving for
someone and then another Financial Peace
University membership and you'll find
somebody deserving that needs to go
through the class you can help them as
coordinators give that away so we'll let
you be the Conduit on that and uh
awesome way to go you guys all right
let's bring the kiddos up I want to know
their names and ages
here we go this is silent she is 11 and
this is Olivia she is eight ooh beaut
Beauties all right excellent job very
good that girl those girls look like
their family tree was changed to me yes
yes very good all right Luis and Delia
Alia Allen
and Olivia in Houston Texas 133
000 paid off in five years making 64 to
135 count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
yeah
yeah very cool stuff
very cool stuff
so Jay that was kind of you and Sam I
mean you guys went through the class
then you ended up coordinating how many
concerts did y'all coordinate at your
church before you came here five five
classes and that look if you're out
there you're walking through the baby
steps you're in baby step two even if
you're in three four five or six this is
how you stay committed and this is how
you stay motivated is you you do the
stuff and you teach the stuff and the
more you teach the stuff you the more
you want to do this stuff oh by the way
coordinators go through the class free
yeah so if you just wanted to go through
the class for free start a class that's
a great idea yeah that's a great idea
you do that all the stuff's on our
website we'll show you how just go to
ramsaysolutions.com and uh the the
reason this class works is a we're
teaching biblically based Common Sense
education and empowerment I mean it's
God's what God's and Grandma's ways of
having money live on less than you make
live on a plan save and invest be
outrageously generous uh you know
understand what you're doing with real
estate with insurance the two things
that people do that mess them up all the
time time right make sure you've this is
the class that you should have been
taught at like 15 years old oh 16 years
old but no one was taught this and so
we've got an entire series of
generations walking around in America
that don't have basic personal finance
info so we're going to give you the
information here's the thing none of the
information is going to go is going to
blow your mind none of it's going to be
like oh I never heard that that's so
complicated it's going to be like
unbelievably easy to understand and hard
to do because you've got to control the
person in your mirror which is the
hardest thing you'll ever do in your
life I figured out if I could get the
guy in my mirror to behave he could be
skinny and Rich oh yeah you know in my
in my financial peace class I'm finding
right now we're talking about credit
cards Dave and and cutting up the credit
cards and people are they have lost
touch with trusting themselves to stick
to the budget I trust that I can stick
to the budget I trust that I can handle
my own money I trust that I can do what
I what I said I was going to do and uh
that's what we teach you to do we trust
you to make a deal with yourself and
keep your end of the bargain that's it
and then the magic of the class the the
big thing is the people in the class yes
the coordinators like Jade the
coordinators like that couple we're a
community the other the other members of
the class that are encouraging you oh
and they'll hold you accountable too if
you want to do stupid they'll argue with
you oh yeah because they're going to
love you enough to to help you stay on
track oh yeah we hold each other
accountable I see price and Veronica and
Stacy twice a week there you go this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host hey get ready for the experience
of a lifetime at the Smart conference
weekend it's going to be April 14th and
15th here in Nashville the inaugural
event of the brand new Ramsey Event
Center we're all really excited about it
around here it is a beautiful new
building up on top of the hill here and
we're looking forward to having about
2500 of our closest friends in for this
if you've never been to one of these
Live Events we go all out for our fans
and this one big time we're going to
because it's the first ever event you're
going to get a uh
memorabilia what do you call it a uh uh
oh my gosh the ticket is a uh oh like a
collectible a collectible ticket if you
come to this one it's pretty cool Ramsay
personalities Rachel Cruz Dr John
deloney George Campbell Ken Coleman
Christina Alice Jade warshaw and myself
are going to give you a plan to improve
every area of your life it is all day
Saturday but before Saturday we're going
to have a big bunch of stuff going on
Friday the live broadcast of the Ramsey
Show we've got some Nashville
oh yeah National surprise some uh some
of the folks in the music business
around here are going to stop by and
hang out with us on uh on Friday night
and after the event so I mean after the
show and then we'll of course do the
SMART conference all day on Saturday
Platinum a VIP tickets long ago sold out
you can still get General access tickets
for 119 dollars there's just a few of
those left though go to
ramsesolutions.com
events today to get your smart
conference weekend tickets they are
coming Jason is in Napa hi Jason welcome
to the Ramsay show
thank you very much Dave thank you Jade
I appreciate it sure what's up
um
looking for a little what would Dave do
um married I'm 47 wife is 37. we are on
baby step six
we make about 195 combined
our combined nest egg is about 285 and
we are now looking to sell our condo and
move into a house
uh we should be able to pull about 200
from the sale to put towards the new
purchase
my question is we have another
non-retirement brokerage account with
about 170 in it would you pull that out
and apply it toward the down payment as
well I would have already if you're in
baby step six is what you should have
already done
you should have already paid it down on
the condo
gotcha it was hers pre-marriage
um but are we gonna are we married are
we staying married
oh absolutely okay I don't give a crap
about pre-marriage then it's now hours
yes understood yeah yeah so I mean
definitely
definitely yeah it sounds like you're
going to move up in house and we are
your new payment's going to be something
you can pay off how quickly
uh we are looking at 12 to 15 year
payoff okay all right yeah so we're
going to be paying it off faster than uh
anticipated you'll put it on a 15-year
mortgage put it on a 15-year fix where
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay and I'd be aiming at
paying it off sub 10.
that would be aggressive and we will
look at that for sure well you're if
you're interested if your income doesn't
go up but your income's going to go up
so it's not really that aggressive
yeah so we are on that track uh as well
as being retired uh or planning to
retire about that same time so pay off
the house and retire
but happily ever after ding ding sounds
like a plan brother thank you for
calling in
that's the plan that's what we're going
to do so baby step six Works where you
don't have any money
anywhere except your emergency fund and
money you're saving to pay for Christmas
yes and we don't have side brokerage
accounts while we still have a mortgage
yeah there's that and I'm also thinking
about I kind of wanted to hit on this
briefly which is the it's our money deal
yeah go ahead and hit on that if you've
got if you're married the money is ours
and I know a lot of people struggle with
that but if you're married go ahead and
combine your finances I tell folks all
the time you need to do a vocab rehab
which is basically taking the words me
my his hers out of the money
conversation and it's ours we need to
get on a budget our money needs to you
know it's we an hour and that that
counts for the money and that counts for
the debt so that's just a quick little
kick in the pants for you guys is that a
jadism a vocab rehab vesogaidism right
there vocab rehab the vocab rehab I'm
going with that I like it it's got you
know we're gonna have to start
collecting these jadisms James I think
they might be valuable someday well
hopefully you guys remember that so go
go home and tell your spouse I heard
some crazy lady on the Ramsay show and
she said you can't you can't say anymore
you're spending and that's your debt she
said it's our debt and you would be
right about that so go home and start
some arguments and uh one of the most
poetic things that I've ever heard about
that that I just love is and it kind of
it Harkens back to yesteryear when uh
when some things were a lot worse and
some things were a lot better
um I mean it's good that we have
Penicillin and it's good we have indoor
plumbing now all right um so we don't
want to harken back to yesteryear for
everything but uh yesteryear was good in
the old marriage vows in the book of
common prayer I mean we all kind of know
the vow the for richer for poor and
sickness and health right uh until death
it was part right that's kind of that
still shows up in a lot of marriage vows
even today but the old book of common
prayer was and unto thee all my worldly
Goods I Pledge yes
there it is it becomes ours yes I don't
get to just keep this little thing to
the side we don't we are now French yeah
we yeah and where your money is is also
so I would have a hard time with with my
spouse saying yes to all of this but no
to the money
because I'm wondering is your heart with
me
yeah
absolutely not Rachel Cruz catches hell
on Instagram and everywhere else anytime
she talks about having joint checking
account but she says you know if you can
share a bed surely you can share a
checking account surely you know sure
don't call me Shirley love it love it
love it all right Kathy's in Pensacola
hey Kathy what's up
all right so I'm wondering if in our
situation it makes sense for me to take
my Social Security early in order to pay
off our mortgage
oh I like it I like your mortgage being
paid off
uh you can't you can't pay it off early
without doing that
no
you don't mean money
no we have money how much money do you
have
cash or everything everything
and how much is your mortgage
113. why don't you just pay off your
stupid mortgage
113 000 you can get your hands on
out of a million
yes pay it off you don't have to mess up
your Social Security to do that
a large portion of our cash is a
personal injury money that I received
and is intended to make up for the loss
of income long term that I've had from
my inability to work
I'm currently I'm currently on
disability we bought onoc policies a
long time ago that will end how old are
you at 66 62 I'm 62. okay but you have a
million dollars and so
right now yes well no but I have it yes
but again is it invested retirement yes
about four and a quarter is retirement
about 275 is equity and Equity equity
and equ in in mutual funds in the home
oh in the home okay all right and then
pay off your mortgage um pay off your
mortgage and make sure your personal
injury money and your retirement are all
invested in good mutual funds which
should average well above 10 percent the
market has since it began
so what
pay off the mortgage
the injury monies are the injuries done
I mean you you've got it's over it's not
over you're still suffering I'm not
making fun of you but that money is
there to invest for you to live off of
the income also if you use some of it to
pay off your mortgage you need less
income to live because you don't have a
mortgage anymore
this is true and and my hesitance on
that has been twofold one is the amount
of our mortgage is only about 640 a
month the pni but you're not right take
out your Social Security early to pay it
off because you're acting like you're a
broke person because you pigeonholed
this money emotionally because it's
associated with your injury
the injury the money is no longer
associated with the injury the money's
just now part of your net worth that you
are going to spend the rest of your life
living on and you should use it to pay
off your mortgage today
football wasn't unclear this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade warshaw
Ramsey personalities my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Greg is with us
in Fort Lauderdale hey Greg welcome to
the Ramsey chef
hey Dave thanks for having me I sold my
place in California ended up with six
hundred thousand dollars in cash
and there's this beautiful Penthouse
condo in Pompano Beach I'm looking at
and I want you to tell me if it's the
dumbest thing in the world to buy it I
love Pompano Beach can I just tell you
that's my old hood
so I'm just throwing that out there
beautiful place yeah yeah it is well the
thing is it's uh 12.50 a thousand two
hundred fifty dollars for the
maintenance fee is the Killer and then
I'd have to maybe get a little bit of a
mortgage above the 600 000 I got for
cash from my California place they
bought it for 750 in other words I have
that maintenance fee and who knows there
might be some ridiculous assessment for
say forty thousand dollars or something
you know so I'd be dealing with that but
I am single with no children
and uh I wonder if it's a fun great move
I mean it's a wonderful place or if it's
just stupid
what's your household income
uh I I'd say now I'm making about uh
between 50 75 000 a year 60 years old
okay
[Music]
so here's I mean I I want you in five
years to pay off whatever mortgage it is
or three years can you do that right
yeah you don't be sick you don't be 65.
you can't do that yeah you don't be 65
with a mortgage and a twelve thousand
dollar earn a twelve hundred dollar
maintenance fee
right as long as you're able to get it
to where that that mortgage with all the
fees included all the taxes all the fees
included is no more than 25 of your
monthly take home are you able to do it
oh yeah
uh yeah well I have to add that up I
have to think about it yeah I think I
think it but you it really needs to be
more than that because you've got to pay
you got to just say you're gonna take
out like 150 000 mortgage
and you got you know like you need to be
putting 40 or 50 000 on this thing ever
ever in licks I mean you need to be
hitting it hard
because because I want you to death I
don't want the condo with a dadgum loan
on it when you go into retirement right
right she got five years to clear this
so thirty thousand a year for five years
is 150.
okay can I got a couple million bucks
I've saved up too I've got investment
well there's a detail you left out come
on come on well you didn't ask I like to
I wanted to ask I wanted to answer the
question you like living life on the
edge I'm getting played here go get the
car dude go get the condo and write a
check for it don't take out a mortgage
just pay cash man just pay cash for it
and take out a mortgage oh my gosh
Caroline's in Cincinnati hey Caroline
how are you
better than I deserve what's up
so I am a 23 year old nursing student I
live on my own I rent an apartment and
I'm on baby step two currently
um I am 11 000 in credit card debt and
I'm also currently taking out student
loans of three thousand dollars a
semester and a thousand of that is to
help me pay my Escape car payment why
are you still taking out student loans
she's still in nursing school
you're doing that for nursing school
you're paying student loans with nursing
school is there any way that you can
cash flow nursing school
I started it that way but with my income
it just wasn't working now what do you
own your car
I owe ten thousand
so you're taking out student loans to
pay for school and you said a thousand
of it is going towards your car
yes yes student loans is 6k a year don't
do it I I need we need to stop the
bleeding on this and I'm telling you
this as somebody who did that
I was I was a person who I was a little
bit Dumber I had a full scholarship and
I took out student loans to fund my
lifestyle and part of that was taking
out money to buy a quote cash vehicle
I took student loans out took the cash
and bought a vehicle don't do it because
you're gonna have to pay it back and
you're gonna have to pay it back with
interest let's try to slow down the
schooling so that you can pay for it in
cash and work your way through Caroline
how long before you graduate
three years three years
yeah okay and how are you covering all
of it you said you're covering all of it
but three thousand dollars and some of
the three thousand is going to the car
so you're covering most of it it sounds
like already how are you doing that
I do have
the close the two I mean the two
thousand it's you're so close you're
within range of being able to pay cash
for this
you're right if you didn't have a car
payment and you made a little bit more
money
you would almost be there wouldn't you
yeah I make 30k a year currently so
what are you doing
I'm a manager at a restaurant
all right um
okay number one your goal is a great
goal a Nursing degree
fabulous line of work
great humans do that and there's always
great career opportunity you got the
opportunity to make a lot of money with
this degree so I want you to get the
degree so what I don't want you to do is
like Jade said I don't want you to go
out and get the degree and then have
this anchor tied around your neck when
you walk down to get your diploma okay
how much student loan debt do you have
today
I've only been taking out student loans
for one semester so just about three
thousand three thousand and how much
credit card debt do you have today
11 000. how did you cover it before in
the other semesters
I would cons is there possible that you
can pull back on your hours of school so
that you can work no not the nursing
degrees are set or it's it's set like
you're not you're not allowed to move
your syllabus around you have to work it
exactly like laid out don't you
yeah yeah okay okay so uh
I'm gonna if I if I were in your shoes
what would I do okay is this good listen
you have to choose
which thing's gonna suck
okay okay you're either going to be
tired
or you're going to have student loan
debt and later on you're going to be
tired
okay yeah so it's you know you might as
well decide which one because one of
these is going to suck
I would prefer to get it out of the way
now if it's me
um I shouldn't tell a nursing student
this but I'd you know rip the Band-Aid
off fast guy okay so uh I want to get it
over with and so if I'm you I'm gonna
sell the car move down into a hoop D and
I'm going to take all the hours it takes
to pay cash for this so that I don't
make a bigger mess if you don't pay down
on anything until you get out I'm okay
with that but I don't want you adding
any more to it because you're tired and
I know it's hard your curriculum is
tough your studies are tough working is
tough I'm not saying it's easy but
neither is paying off thirty thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt later
yeah because that's a slow burn that
accumulates fast you're doing you're
doing the right thing I know that you
can do this
and I would also poke around the nursing
school and ask one more around where
what else can I get for some more
Scholars how much other Aid can I get I
need some help here I'm dying over here
yeah
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
when was the last time you were excited
about a Monday
What If instead of waking up exhausted
you felt exhilarated can't wait to get
to work because it's another day to
fulfill your passion your dream job
in a world where bare minimum Monday has
taken the place of quiet quitting in a
world where we are have a group of
morons who are now worshiping the art of
mediocrity
maybe you ought to plug into something
where you can reach for excellence or
you can actually get fired up and wired
up about your life again and go be
somebody instead of trying to manage
average no let's don't do that let's
don't do bare minimum Monday that makes
me sick just saying it get a little
throw up in my throat right then
bare minimum Monday that's just awful
it's just gross so this is why career
expert and Ramsey personality Ken
Coleman created the get clear assessment
to help you discover your top talents
passions and a clear mission statement
that'll help you find the work the world
needs you to do
and after taking the quick assessment
you'll get a custom Report with
everything you need to take that first
step toward a career that you love a
meaningful career that you will plug
into and leave it all on the field baby
hey Joy start your journey by taking the
get clear assessment at
ramseysolutions.com get clear Shale is
with us in Nashville hi Dale welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for taking the call but
listen I have had to sell my mom's house
in order to pay for her Assisted Living
so I've got the money just sitting in a
checking account and I need to do
something with it now I know you're not
a big fan of CDs but you know short term
I I don't know if there's a better
alternative
there's not much better um it's not
going to make much difference though how
much money is it
uh 260 000. okay and how much is our
care costing
uh 66 000 a year
okay how old is she
um how's she doing
she's in a memory care unit
um you know at 90 years old she has the
typical you know high blood pressure
heart disease
cholesterol but other than that she's
doing quite well okay I mean she can
carry on a conversation with you but she
just doesn't have pretty much memory
yeah
man I'm sorry for what you're walking
through thank you for being a good man
and taking care of your mother
um but I'm just trying to be a good
Steward of her money so if you're trying
to figure out what's going to be best
yeah so if you make one percent more on
it you're gonna make two thousand
dollars more
okay okay and um and so if you can get a
CD that's making two percent you're
gonna make five thousand dollars more so
five thousand dollars and we then you
have 260 000 in the bank does not change
the equation much
does that make sense to you
yeah yeah yeah and so
um
the uh uh yes go ahead and put it in a
CD uh because that's better than that
it's better it's five thousand dollars
more than you would have had
yeah yeah what's your bank quoting you
on a CD
um
uh for 12 months 5.45 that's good yeah
so that's five percent more than you
would have had yeah I would do that yeah
definitely
but and then you know and you know lock
up all but sixty thousand bucks of it
right so put 200 of it in that
yeah I was well I I didn't know whether
to do it in a mix of doing like part of
it the money in a 12-month part of it in
a nine month part of it in a six month
in case uh having helped me that if
something should come up and I'm needing
to liquidate earlier than 12 months
again I would have to six months and
have that in maturity if you have to
liquidate earlier than 12 months it
means you just don't get all the
interest
they don't take they don't take any of
your principal
so it'll just be you get less than five
so it's not the end of the world
yeah my goal is just to keep keep it
until maturity now I'm going to try to
keep enough I'd put it at least 100 I'd
put at least 150 in for a year at five
for a 150 for what for a year at five
percent yeah oh okay at least okay and
that that leaves you 90 grand 90 grand
will cover any contingencies and if you
don't quite get the five because
something happens and you end up
liquidating sooner than so what it's not
the end of the world okay you're not
gonna lose any money
okay yeah I can't afford that I mean
that so yeah the point is We're Not
Gonna uh you're not gonna make
substantial money on this with this type
of thing but it is it's better than than
leaving it sitting there making one
percent in a stupid savings account
right so yeah if you can get five in
this current market that's a good thing
I'd step on that and um I personally
probably put 200 in there but at least
150 uh because the 60s one year's worth
of expenses and then again if you
liquidate early you don't lose anything
except a portion of the returns you lose
none of the principles so it's not they
uh it's not that big a deal really uh
it's just a we're gonna take a take a
run at it here so for somebody listening
who's going through something similar at
what point Dave would you invest that
money Beyond a CD
if Mom was younger
where I generally investing means I'm
going to mutual funds and that means I
need a a 97 of the five-year periods in
history in the stock market have made
money so if you're in good mutual funds
you leave it alone five years the 97
percent of the time you will make money
all right and uh only about 64 67
percent of the three-year periods make
money so
um I put money in mutual funds that I'm
going to leave alone a year but and I
might lose some money after a year if I
want to move it over into some real
estate but you can stomach I can afford
I can mathematically afford that hit it
doesn't affect my life but he can't
afford to lose 26 000 out of this 260
can't lose 10 percent would be a lot
um and chasing ten percent you know so
we don't want to take that risk here but
if if uh if Mom was uh in really really
really good good health uh had uh
uh some early signs of Alzheimer's and
was in nursing care and she was 62.
right now we've got a life expectancy
that is much longer statistically
speaking exactly
um and we might say okay some of this
money we could park for five years and
we could take a chance with it and make
you know some good returns like instead
of 5 10 or 11 12 something like that on
mutual fund so but yeah if you're not
going to leave it alone five years we
call it saving
right if you're gonna leave it alone
five years it's investing right and so
that's the the Bell weather that we use
around here and and so what we're doing
with Dale is we're helping him save some
of his mom's money in the best possible
savings account but that's not really
investing right at that stage so good
good questions Debbie is in Raleigh
North Carolina hey Debbie welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave and Jane I'm so glad to talk to
you and um it's got a big argument with
my husband so I'm gonna go with your
answer so I hope it's a good one
um
we are going from two incomes to one
income so for the first time we're
really going to try and set a budget my
husband thinks the way you figure out a
budget is look at what we've spent over
the last six to 12 months and then
that's how we figure out our budget
going forward whereas I figure no we
just have to look at what our what our
monthly income is going to be and then
we have to give each category a dollar
amount and go from there because it
doesn't really matter what we spent
before because we're not going to have
that same income well you understand I
do I do you're you're kind of both right
I get what he's saying he's if you've
never done a budget before you don't
know what it is that you're spending so
yeah going back and looking at past bank
statements and seeing what did we spend
on groceries how much are we really
spending on gas going back to see that
is is a great place to start let's say
you spent uh 300 on gas and nothing has
changed and you do a new budget with
your new income you go we need to spend
150 on gas you're not going to make it
that's not going to work you're
basically got to chop it in half so I
mean but if you looked at your old
budget and go well that's changed
because you know we're not driving to
work anymore one of us isn't working you
know gas bill is going to go down yeah
then you can make adjustments for that
but he you're right Jay both of you are
right you should take your current
income and spend it all on paper before
the month begins it's called a
zero-based budget and a good indicator
of what you're going to need for that is
what you used to do adjusting for
whatever has changed right since then
but or what you're willing to change
since then that kind of thing what
you're able to change and adjust since
then so they're both right this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsey Show Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt-free stage Rick and Tiffany are
with us hey guys how are you join us
this is awesome so good to have you guys
where do you live
just outside of Concord New Hampshire ah
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off
we've paid off
353.85 love it how long did this take
about 59 months 59 months and your range
of income during that time
range from 83 000 to 140 000. cool what
do you all do for a living
I'm a self-employed I design specialized
Refrigeration equipment
and Tiffany is I do accounting for a
non-profit in human services excellent
very good cool what kind of debt was 176
thousand
or so was a couple of small student
loans
um a uh two cars and
um
a credit card and it's kind of normal
and then we paid off our house
yay looking at weird people okay so tell
us the story and tell us the story on
the live debt free or die
we're from New Hampshire and that is the
state motto is Live Free or Die right so
we just modified it a little bit for the
show
exactly it's almost like a threat
[Laughter]
okay so what got you guys going 59
months ago what's your story well
several years ago some idiot told me
that
all of my credit card debt and
everything that I had before we got
married was my responsibility and she
wouldn't have to deal with it if I died
and a bigger idiot believed it
so I went on just keeping on going until
I found out that that wasn't true and
that I if I died I would be leaving her
with that debt
so we uh we thought about it I my credit
union had a special for consolidating
loans that they would do everything in
three years I said no I want to do it in
two
so we paid off the credit card was it 32
000 I think at that time and we did that
in about 18 months
and Tiffany brought up the uh
money yeah
again and we had talked about it a long
time ago we heard it from our church
about financial peace and I was young
and stupid and said why am I paying a
hundred dollars to learn how to save
money
um
I decided I was just stupid that's all
well Tiffany how did you get him to
realize that he was being stupid
in your own words Rick in your own words
well I just saw how dedicated he was
um and just to give you a little back
story there is 18 years difference
between us so she's a little older
so for him to have it on his heart that
he that he felt bad to you know
um
to leave me with the dead if anything
would happen although he's in much
better shape than I am he just went out
for a seven mile run this morning there
you go
um but
so I was I'm not one that likes clutter
in my house so I was doing some research
and came up with the minimalists oh yeah
and you come hand in hand with them yeah
they're good they're good friends of
ours yeah yeah so
um it was
um New Year's Eve I think uh weekend or
something like that and we had a long
weekend and I
I took the book out from the library and
I'm not a very fast reader I read the
whole book in like two days
um but I didn't want it's not like it's
a literary work of art yeah
but I didn't really want to push it on
him yet so
um I just saw some things that changed
in him as well because this really this
journey had changed our marriage
um it increased our faith we went from
paying like maybe like an offering to
our church and I'm you know he brought
up to me I really want to start tithing
and that was huge
um
so we do a lot of traveling my dad lives
in South Carolina which is a 17-hour
drive and he does all the driving
um
and so you're the dj so I put the
podcast
you can't get out you're stuck with Dave
yeah and uh he he was enjoying it I mean
that's a 17-hour drive each way we'd go
twice a year so 17 hours a day yeah yeah
more days than I want is that I'm not
going to touch it
and I just want to say too that God is
just provided for us and and the more
that we saw that um
that we were giving the more that we'd
get back and I was like I don't
understand this and uh and the more you
start doing smart stuff the more He
blesses you yes when you're faithful in
the little things it gives you more to
manage right and um he had a great uh
sales year
um back in 2019 and he knew it was my
desire to finish my degree
it's uh I finished my associate's degree
there's probably a picture there
um in 28 years it was just something
that for my children I just wanted and
my grandchildren you know to see that
and it was just important for me and my
mom too my dad who are still with me and
um but anyway so he's like you know I
had a good year I mean let's pause the
journey still pay you know at that point
we're paying we had already paid off all
our Consumer Debt um but let's you know
kind of pause and pay a little bit you
know do the house payment but get this
degree done so I gave my um notice to my
work January 2020 I gave them three
months notice perfect yeah so March 10th
I think was my last day talk about
perfect time yeah right in time for
covet right but and Rick can explain
about his job but I mean
we should have been afraid but God that
was like the probably one of the best
years you had financially because of
your essential work right yeah it's a
central business so we kept in business
we kept producing as best we could and
and people kept asking for more and more
and more and it worked out just well she
was able to go back to school and finish
her degree and then we finished paying
off the house yeah
go ahead a side note too is
I've been self-employed most of my life
and finally two weeks before I turned 66
I opened my first Ira
there you go why not yeah it's all part
of the program that's right well
congratulations you guys how's it feel
to be free oh my goodness yeah
um we because one of the things we gave
up was
um we love to cruise we were doing a
couple of cruises a year we gave that up
so we were able to do our first uh
debt-free Cruise oh cool wow yeah a
couple of months ago yeah yeah where'd
you go to the Bahamas yeah it was good
yeah it was good we've got the live and
give box for you that's the baby steps
millionaires book uh I got a feeling
you're there uh how much is in your
all's retirement accounts well it's
fluctuated because you know probably
about 75 000. I put it in just in time
what's the housework I looked it up
today 360
000. so you're on your way you're on
your way then to Baby Steps Millions
we've got that book for you we've got
The Total Money Makeover book for you
Financial Peace University membership
all of those use them or give them use
them or give them that's what they're
for and God bless y'all way to go Heroes
thank you took control of your life well
done Rick and Tiffany Concord New
Hampshire
176 thousand dollars paid off in 59
months making 83 to 140. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
foreign
[Applause]
I love it Live Free or Die live debt
free or die I love it yeah I'll take the
New Hampshire state motto make a little
adjustment oh yeah and we have a new
motto here I love it live debt free or
die
man serious hey it's a good way to live
though it is how do you celebrate you go
on a cruise that's perfect I like it and
it's debt-free it doesn't follow you
home afterwards love it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Matthew 12 36
and I tell you this you must give an
account on Judgment Day for Every Idle
Word you speak I don't even want to
think about that one
after doing all these hours of talk
radio oh my Lord give me Grace Jesus
home uh is it better to offer no excuse
than a bad one George Washington
interesting
you know Dave I think you could be one
of those Bible readers on the Bible app
one of the voices you know you've got
like Morgan Freeman the hillbilly
version of James Earl Jones
University hillbilly redneck version of
the Bible that's the one I would do I'd
like to take a poll on that yeah I'm I'm
up for it I can do it yeah like read the
whole net
sounds like a lot of work don't don't
sign me up for something here what are
you with are you some Publishers curious
some people might like it yeah
all right Aiden is with us in St Louis
Aiden get me out of this how can we help
doing all right how's it going better
than I deserve man how can we help
yeah so um
a weekend trip to Texas and I messed up
and bought a car while I was there are
you drinking
um no I just I saw the car before I went
down there and it's my dream car and I
just messed up and ended up doing it now
I can't get the thought out of my head
that I could be using that money for a
down payment on a house what car was it
and how much did it cost you
the car was 20 000 and it's a 2013
Nissan 370Z what's the payment on that
uh my total payment works out to around
450 a month
and what were you driving before
a 2002 Honda Accord with 275 000 miles
and it's broke in on me like four times
in the past two months how'd you get to
Texas
um I just went with my buddy okay so you
still got the Accord
yeah
how old are you
19.
okay
um
and and what's your question sir
just
I just don't know if I should keep the
car and deal with it because I and pay
the stupid taxes you say because I know
I messed up
or what to do from here because I
I mean I can afford I mean I can afford
the payment and you know between me and
my fiance we make enough money where
it's not exactly a big Financial strain
on us but I just can't shake that idea
of the down payment on a house there's
not an us you're not married
yeah well so we get married uh in a
month from now oh okay so you just
saddled her with a car payment instead
of a house yeah I bet she's happy
she kind of told me she thought that I
deserve to have something at least kind
of nice but she said she's gonna we're
gonna work as it on it as a team
together what's your income now and
what's your income going to be when
you're married
so my income now is about 3 500 bucks a
month
um through my night job and then I just
got my real estate license at the end of
last year
um and then she makes around three three
thousand dollars a month and so it'll be
around 6 500 bucks a month without
without anything from Real Estate okay
um
wow can I ask what other debt you have
in between with her as well
neither of us have any other debt other
than this I've got
um I personally I have a little bit of
cash about around three three months
worth of expenses I've got 6 000 in a
Roth 2500 in mutual funds and this is
like my first ever mess up essentially
and then she has around 20K cash with no
investment okay I want you to tell her I
said this okay
okay you don't deserve the car she's
wrong
if you deserved it you would have had
the money to pay for it
you don't deserve 450 car payments
you're not that bad a guy
yes you don't deserve hell
okay so I'm not gonna you know know you
know you're deserve something when you
have saved the money and you pay for it
until then you don't deserve it
that was a that's a childish statement
and if you if you repeat that statement
over and over you're going to be broke
your whole life
yeah
I deserve it now that's McDonald's I
deserve a break today you're gonna
deserve a Big Mac that's the best you
can do
seriously so uh what would I do if I
woke up in your shoes is I would sell
the car because you have cost your
family the down payment and I would get
rid of it and you made a mistake you
impulsed and um you made a
and and the other thing Aiden that uh I
do when I pay stupid taxes I want to do
an autopsy and a CSI on the situation
and go okay what was going on that
allowed me to be this stupid
was it was it your buddy
I think I was just
friends and
really wanted I just wanted a nicer car
because my car you know what what
process is going on in your life what
process is going on in your spirit in
your intellect in your decision-making
Paradigm that allows you to make this
bad decision you know you want to know
that so you don't do it again right
yeah because I think it's if you impulse
20 000 items and your fiance says I you
deserve it you're you're going to be
broke your whole life man and so the bad
news is you made a mistake the good news
is you're only 19 and you have the whole
rest of your life to never impulse a car
again yeah you might do some other dumb
things but let's take that one off the
table this is the last time you're gonna
do this one check never do that one
again because it's going to cost you
some money by the time you get out of it
you're probably not even going to get
out of it without writing a check right
and so it's going to set you back but I
I wouldn't
I would get rid of it because of how it
occurred well he's never going to be
able to even he's never going to be able
to enjoy the car because of the way he
feels about how he purchased it he's
it's it's always going to be that burden
to him feels like he's got a financial
hangover right yeah
yeah I'd sell it too I mean numbers wise
they could probably make it work but
it's I think it's a principle here and
it's honestly it's how they're setting
their marriage off and that's not the
foot I'd want to set it off I I
I think I'm admitting that what I did
was a bad idea by getting rid of it I
think by keeping it in some way you're
endorsing this saying some portion of
the decision was a good decision right
right and honestly none of it was yeah
so I think it's a it's not really about
the car and it's not even about twenty
thousand dollars with their you know
with their eighty thousand dollar income
it's more about I've got to make sure my
brain never works this way again because
it didn't work well yeah when I was
doing this and you're the sum of the
people you hang around I just want to
throw that out there
um it sounded like whoever he was with
isn't it had an influence on him being
an idiot yeah because yeah if you're
gonna listen if if you run around with
your drinking buddies you're gonna have
a drinking problem heck yeah this is how
it works I mean this is not you become
who you hang around with that's right so
you just gotta you gotta watch this
stuff it's uh
yeah I'm I'm
uh I I want to be hard not on you Aiden
because you made a mistake that almost
everyone in America has made it one time
or another in their lives but I do want
to be very very hard on the actual event
I want to be very hard on the way your
brain was working during that event so
that you don't re repeat right and you
don't have to live with this kind of
pain that you know when Sharon and I
went broke Aiden and we lost everything
we were 28 years old we had a brand new
baby and a toddler and a marriage
Hanging On by a thread
one of the benefits of having gone broke
at that age and lost a million dollar
net worth lost four million dollars
worth of real estate is I got the
opportunity to repeatedly do what you're
doing or what I'm asking you to do and
that's doing autopsy on my stupidity you
know okay what killed the patient
why did he die you know is it what's the
comorbid I mean we know it was covered
but what's the co-morbidity right so
comorbidity it had to be coveted it's
everything's coveted but we you know but
he but it's a reminder run over by a car
when he had coveted but he died of covet
you know but let's really get to looking
at what really really happened here
with a patient why did the patient
expire why did I make this stupid butt
decision and I had to unpack that and I
spent
actually a year or more unpacking that
so that I never went back again right
and thus was born what we teach every
day I love that so there you go go
through the process people it puts this
hour the Ramsey showing the book so
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]